Hello, hello, everyone!
Kurokori Toki is back, and we are here to blow some bubbles!
Yes, that's right!
Today, I am sponsored by Bubble Bobble Sugar Dungeons to
check out their newest game in the franchise.
If you guys didn't know, I've grown up with this game since
I was very little, and even played the Puzzle Bubble series.
So when I saw that they reached out, I told my manager, You
have to say yes!
And make childhood Toki's dreams come true!
But yes, it is currently available now on Steam,
PlayStation, and Switch.
Yeah!
As always, Dragons, make sure to click the link in the
description below and try to game out yourself.
Thank you for letting me go back to my childhood and play
Bubble Bubble Sugar Dungeons.
Okay, enough yapping from this pre-recorded dokey.
It's time to play the game, other pre-recorded dokey.
Thank you for another amazing intro pre-recorded dokey.
God, you're so good at this.
Like I said, I used to play the classic Bubble Bubble games
a lot growing up, and apparently I heard that This blends in
the classic mechanics with new abilities and the dungeons
are procedurally generated.
So that means there's a lot of replayability.
So they also have Bubble Symphony for the classic enjoyers
too.
So for those who remember that game, this is for you.
All right, let's get into it.
Straight in.
Oh, there's me.
I'm Bub.
Is anyone there?
Ha ha.
Whoa, you scared me.
Why?
I don't think we met before.
My name.
is don't chant don't say don't don't i'll just call you
don't there's a reason i've transferred you here to give you
a mission take on the dungeons i've prepared and gathered
all the treasures inside i get to go on a real big adventure
right that's right but my schedule is just so packed i'll
let me handle the rest oh nice to meet nice to meet you bub
i'm i mean so how did i get on Adventure.
Not so fast, Bob.
Think you could start by trying out the training I prepared
for you?
I've been doing this for 30 years, bro.
I don't need no training.
Alright, basic operations.
Oh.
Okay, that's new.
Usually I would just do this, but oh, now I can just hit it
with my head.
Oh, that's new.
That's cute.
Come on, get in there.
There you go.
Oh!
Okay, oops.
Sorry.
Touched my toe.
Guys, I didn't lose in that baby level.
I just, he went like, did anyone get his lessons?
He was so fast.
It could have happened to anybody, guys.
There you go.
See, look at that.
Easy.
Blow bubble, you pop bubble.
That's right.
Get in here.
I got my comp.
Oh, so the sparkle shows like where the bubble is gonna go.
I'm so good at puzzles.
New counter gate beyond yet.
Let's take them out and head inside.
Okay, so I got this.
inventory that is new and then how do I I want to oh IP
there you go I was like why is it why can't I use it is it
locked or something oh there we go oh that's cool I don't
want bottom then just have lots of keys that leads to
various places try going through them all okay hello got my
drink my treasure now finders keepers yeah I did it I beat
the tutorial wait what what a treasure is that fruit and
then one singular ruby you'll see an exclamation mark on me
whenever you complete a mission so be sure to come and over
and say hello god i love that it's okay to talk to you when
you don't have an exclamation mark on you of course talking
to you oh that's sad oh my gosh she has no one to talk to
god it's so it's like nostalgia but new at the same time oh
oh Ha ha, burn!
Yoink, mine now.
Oh, it's timed.
I just noticed the timer.
Wait, what's this?
Oh, I have to go to the secret.
There's a secret entrance.
Yay.
I assume this is the secret.
Excellent escape.
Oh!
I could have went even further.
I didn't know that.
Wait, I want to go back.
Yeah, try again.
I didn't realize I could go further in the dungeon.
It's not that I didn't know.
I just know that that was the exit.
I just wanted to show you guys the replayability of the
procedural generated dungeon.
Oh my gosh, I'm so smart.
Oh, question mark.
What the question mark do?
I want to go through the question mark.
Two, three.
Wait, where am I?
Oh, oh, oh, um, um, okay, it's fine.
No, guys, I did not lose in a baby level.
How is I supposed to know?
There were 20 plus enemies in front of me.
You're like, oh, Doki, you should have used your abilities.
How is I supposed to know that?
Okay, there's still five more to go.
Oh, I'm running out of time.
I just noticed how little time I have.
Oh, it's up, up, up, up.
That's like all the way to the boss level.
There you go.
All right, 10.
All right, this has to be the boss fight, right?
Oh, it's just extra.
I don't even have like...
Oh, that's right.
Don't got me.
Yeah, I'm not afraid of you.
I just sped run all the way here.
Get in here.
Get in my bubble.
Pop.
That's right.
All your friends are gone.
I popped them all.
Yay!
Did it!
Excellent escape.
We did it.
We got the dungeon.
That means we unlock a new dungeon, right?
Sayoma!
Yay!
Okay.
Got wooden chest.
I'm sorry, wooden crate.
Cafe, oh, wood, sorry.
Third time, wooden's cafe.
Wallen!
Wow, you're here, too, Wallen?
What are you doing here?
Come on, hurry over here.
Learn more by checking out the cafe's menu.
Will enjoy all your adventures.
Okay, so, oh, this is the fire drink.
What's the long shot?
Shoot, wait, shoot fire.
Oh, I can shoot fire, but donut.
Oh, the donut is a fast travel.
Wait, I want to try.
I'll try to long shot.
Yeah, another mission complete.
I did it.
I was nice and easy, huh?
I hope my sweets help you keep on adventuring.
Ayompa!
Thanks, Willan.
You're such a huge help.
We know, we have one more special friend who's working hard
to help you out, right?
Mm-hmm.
Okay, now do that.
Oh, thanks for contacting me.
Go buy the magic library and you might find feeling a lot
better.
Come on, let's head over there.
Oh, all right.
The library is now open.
The biblioteca.
Oh, it's where I can level my skills.
You can get lots of different powers at the magic library.
Oh, okay.
So attack enemies.
Um, I'll do one of each.
I got one of each.
Now my fire is even better now.
Yeah.
I did it.
Oh my God, everybody wants, I'm so popular.
to talk to me.
All three of my friends.
It was fun.
I had a fun time checking out Bubble Bubbles.
Sugar Dungeons.
It was like going back to my childhood.
A lot of nostalgia and everything.
And the popping bubbles and po-yom-pah!
But that's Dragos.
Feel free to check out the game.
Available now on Steam, Switch, and PlayStation.
It was such a joy playing it.
It's so cute.
Everything is so cute.
And po-yom-pah!
I will See you guys next time, everybody.
As always, stay hydrated, pause, check, get up, and move
around to get that blood flow.
And if you stay up for me to watch this video, head to bed,
because you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, Dragons.
Bye-bye.
Plon-yum-pah.
Plon-pah.